[Music]
the question is will Conan O'Brien be as
funny as David let's blood pressure on
his gosh a lot of pressure he has the
the network riding under shoulders well
this is his birthday tonight
oh yeah so they say
lotta pressure
I'll do my best
[Music]
hey yeah better mayor's got his
Leatherman I'll give it a shot
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Conan town broker I just want to be
the first to welcome you to NBC thanks
man and best of luck dude
oh and Conan one more thing you better
be as good as Letterman or else see you
folks out there now or do I have a
minute right now
[Applause]
from NBC Studios in New York in Late
Night with Conan O'Brien
[Music]
tonight John Goodman Drew Barrymore and
Tony Randall with the Max Weinberg 7 why
can't we feed the honey wrong time
now here's your host Conan O'Brien
[Applause]
[Music]
something's wrong something's really
wrong now I'm fine really I'm fine I'm
fine
[Applause]
well I've been in show business now 45
seconds and this is the nicest reception
I ever had
okay so first show I got to admit that
this is a little unusual I mean let's
face it most guys that are in this spot
they came up here a different way you
know I mean a lot of guys they spend
years and years in the club's working
very hard struggling and finally they
get here on TV my plan is to start on TV
claw my way into the clubs but I do feel
very good about this show we have a
really we got a terrific show together
and I've been giving this thing and
giving it a lot of thought alright got a
few months now first of all a lot of
shows guest is out for how long
six minutes seven minutes and then
they're gone you never get to really
know them you know so I thought on this
show
same guests every night
you are really going to get to know John
Goodman the other thing is uh all hosts
I'm serious please I'm trying to run a
show here I'm new come on a lot of hosts
they they have their trademark gesture
of course Carson had the famous golf
swing and Arsenio has this thing I don't
know what it's called but I call it the
Arsenio anyway uh I thought you know I
should have my own trademark gesture and
I worked out some you know options if
you want to see him do you all right
this one's good
you're watching America cuz you're gonna
see a lot of this point
all right I had one other one which is
actually my favorite if you want to see
it sounds like this all right you'll see
it
that's how show business works I can't
bring something up and then not do it
all right here's the other one
hi America
but in all sincerity I am very thrilled
to be here this is long been a dream of
mine and do this and and to do it well
we'll see and and I remember when I was
a kid I used to think about doing it
actually in high school I used to say
remember saying to my friends you know
if there's any way that I could somebody
be a talk show host I'm serious
you people and you know kids are cruel
and I remembered they they started
laughing at me a lot of the time and
they said to me Oh Brian the day you get
your own talk show is the day there's
peace in the Middle East
all right
we have a really great perso and I'm a
complete unknown to everybody and these
people were fantastic to come on its
come on I'm torn O'Brien you better do
my show John Goodman is here first thank
and introduce the Max Weinberg seven
and now I want to please welcome a
friend of mine some might even say a
sidekick
Andy Richter
oh great TV whatever Andy calm
yourselves to be professional now act
like guys that are too young to be on TV
Andy you are of course you won we
scouted hundreds of thousands of people
and you were actually the winner of the
sidekick competition yeah you actually
weren't even entering what happened to
you well I got on the backs of on the
back of a box of doughnuts this scratch
off and win thing right right
Here I am alright thank God I love
doughnuts
[Applause]
alright well Andy you know what it's
time for are you gonna show us a scar
never it's time for actual small town
items this is the part of the show where
we share items that we've found in small
town newspapers that are weird or even
kind of unusual well that's a that is a
really innovative kind of groundbreaking
I guess yes that's the kind of
television I want to do I think we're
gonna make a lot of waves with this one
all right well let's let's get going
here cuz this is you guys ready all
right this one is from Watertown New
York here's a road sign that might give
a lot of people the wrong idea we get a
shot of this actually an actual small
town news I'd a real road sign that's
right
here is an advertisement taken out of
the Wilmington crier of Wilmington North
Carolina watch this is actual of course
we don't want here it's an ad for a hair
replacement Center and please look down
at the bottom it says free order of
french fries with every new set of
Michelin tires
now truth is so much stranger than
fiction I'll say here's an advertisement
from Newton Massachusetts it's for a
miniature golf course
I want you to take a look at this we
found it here our staff the ad reads
bob's mini golf course we are a really
bad miniature golf course you shouldn't
come here
now that that is so obviously real
because you could not make that make
that stuff up oh there's no way just no
way here's another ad this is from the
miners town which is tin miners town
Pennsylvania and it's for the Morris
Funeral Home and take a look at this
it's unbelievable
we will make the death of your loved one
the most frightening and disturbing
experience you've ever endured
[Applause]
you know something people there's
nothing funnier than real items that
weren't faked and doctored by a graphics
department it's got to be real got to be
real or it's not funny that's right all
right now this is this is an article
from the Lexington Daily Mirror of
Lexington Kentucky I read this I just
can't believe it okay a woman is in
critical condition today after being hit
by a bus at a downtown intersection the
victim mrs. Louise hit by a bus was
rushed to County Hospital where she was
operated on by dr. help Louise mrs. hit
by a bus his husband John hope she's
okay spent the night sitting up with her
tell me Andy it's amazing that was an
amazing segment and I hope we can do it
again soon
I'd love to as soon as our research team
can find another batch they're not easy
to find they're doing God's work all
right we will be right back with John
Goodman our very first guest
penny uh as you're well aware it's time
to bring out our very first guest this
is exciting
yeah yes my first guest it is exciting
[Applause]
my first guest is one of America's most
beloved actors you know I'm from
Roseanne you can see him in the upcoming
Flintstones movie please welcome our
first guest ever John Goodman
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah great a couple of years when I
bought them out I can trade this in for
a gallon a cheap scotch I'll need this
thank you all right how's it go well
thank you very much for coming on the
show thanks for asking I wouldn't have
been my first choice what the hey times
are hard John
so uh how's it going it's going good I
just finished the this movie called The
Flintstones what could you have Fred
Flintstone it's about the Stone Age
family and there are modern Stone Age
family don't ruin it well we can we can
stop tape okay no we can't no anyway and
they're gonna have a whole line of
chewables children's vitamins it's gonna
be great but we had a lot of fun doing
it Rick Moranis was Barney Elizabeth
Perkins was um Wilma there would be
Fred's wife right and Rosie O'Donnell's
buddy and Elizabeth Taylor was my
mother-in-law don't we gotten us some
real was kind of a cross between Who's
Afraid of Virginia Woolf and the
honeymooners for a while it was the
Great Gazoo gonna be in the movie oh
that Gazoo no not in this one you give
me the baby if the public likes that
we'll have to do another one you do know
who the Great Gazoo weighs quite a cheap
gymnast oh that's a little space guy
yeah the space creature yeah
and some say ruin the series not in our
movie pal all right now I want a little
outer space pile on this show but the
network says no I'm Olly
Sunim to wardrobe we did gonna buy these
myself so the Flintstones but you're
done with it now uh yeah uh finish that
I was doing in Roseanne and the phone so
it's the same time so I came down with
pneumonia excellent
hi I'm just getting over it but uh you
think this is a this is gonna have
worldwide appeal this movie amazing fun
I don't think so we had a bunch of
foreign press come over just and it
turns out that the Japanese don't know
the Flintstones they've never seen the
Flintstone I have the cartoon over there
so I had to speak to a gentleman from a
Japanese talk-show who asked me through
a translator
booyah huh and the translator said why
do you find it necessary for a primitive
man to wear a necktie well that's what
we got to go for a second we'll have
more with John Goodman when we come back
I'm talking with John Goodman how's it
going what oh right no oh I'm getting a
signal right here we have to be right
back after this special effects
technician
[Music]
[Applause]
we're back
there's so much nonsense to get you on
this show it's difficult sometimes John
I have to ask you something yes sir if I
named after yes I do I'm being paid
you were you were considered one of the
sexiest men by a lot of magazines on TV
it's true magazine that was a US
magazine or one of those reliable
publications and they didn't say what
country's television yeah I was it was a
couple years ago it's kind of
embarrassing
now simultaneously another magazine also
said that you were the star that most
resembled mr. Potato Head
we take a look at that who it was what
was that there we go there's there you
are of course and of course there's mr.
Potato Head coming up area what was that
that was play school I guess the people
that make mr. Potato Head and they chose
you yeah they know the children did they
just a bunch of children and they said
mr. Potato Head has a chubby face just
like mr. Goodman and Michael Jordan came
in second but I can't my daughter's
three now and I can't let her get ahold
of that information because while I'm
sleeping she'll you know those things
are real sharp
excellent now I just want to be the
celebrity that most resembles Raggedy
Andy hang is TV for a while I think it's
interesting that sexy and mr. Potato
Head are somehow you know and in hand
which explains a lot of confusion I
experienced as a child
in directo ladies and gentlemen
yes we're gonna get a plastic shield
built-in I'm gonna get things done the
way I want them you uh but you're
working on a lot of movies you're
working on Roseanne simultaneously yeah
what does John Goodman do to relax to
unwind Oh little naked twister couple
belts of cheap gin and like the leg
Russell really yeah you know what like
wrestling us now what - uh well he could
be either sucks
he likes side by side feet up this way
head down this way and you bring your
legs up and try to throw the other
person over are you serious this is
something you used to do it as a kid
notice but the only thing I was good at
and uh I've never been beaten I mean I
quit for a while cuz I killed a guy
doing it I mean you've never been beaten
no one's ever beaten you on I bet Andy
could take you
John she's getting over pneumonia and
I'm just getting over like three
ruptured bursa
why don't you really
[Applause]
[Music]
isn't there somebody here is there
somebody here who will rest leg wrestle
John Goodman's line somebody anybody
okay I'll do it yeah
[Applause]
I think I think we're finally going to
settle this thing the grudge match
between the burly lovable big guys a TV
[Applause]
enough it's the only thing I'm good at -
darling you know they're all
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right now hold that hold it
come on anyone settle down this is a
this is a serious TV show we you know
the rules of course gentlemen hold hands
I will count you off to three and then
begin leg wrestling all right all right
one
[Applause]
in this half-hour we've got pee
Barrymore and Tony Randall and we'll
tell you who won the leg wrestling
competition but first let's check out
what's coming up on later with Bob
Costas bob thanks Conan coming up on
later something worth giving up that
extra half hours sleep for as we take a
loving look back at the classic film The
Wizard of Oz I'll be talking with the
two surviving cast members all right now
you're 84 and you are 140 you have fond
memories of Judy Garland sure sweet lady
but did she have problems even then she
drank she drank but no more than anyone
else we were all professionals what was
it like working with ray Bolger
[Applause]
Bert Lahr was really a coward
right right back with Drew Barrymore are
you doing great doing alright well thank
you this thing zips up the back few to
get in and out of you look terrific
thank you
now listen I don't want to start off on
the wrong note I don't want to be one of
those talk-show host who's always
gushing but you of the three Amy
Fisher's I think yours was by far the
best right
did you a lot of actors when they're
preparing for a role like that with a
killer or a murder where they actually
go and meet the person in prison did you
do that because I know well let me tell
you a little something about Amy I
didn't get to meet her actually because
she was you know going through all their
court things and being arraigned at the
time of the shooting and it was very
nerve-wracking to be portraying somebody
who is living in the media as we were
shooting and you know trying to pull off
the accent and do the whole thing and
like you know understand everything and
sort of come to terms with why she did
the things she did to have the sincerity
to play her but it was I had to do it I
had to live out that humor I felt for
this girl right you didn't meet with her
you didn't talk to her you just studied
I just sir I would listen to her voice
over and over and over again all right
what was it very I'm saying it was a
very funny portrayal to which a lot of
people wouldn't wouldn't have gone that
way oh well I had I tried to bring the
humor into it you know I'm trying to
write not always easy it isn't but it
was fun it was a we had a really good
time wait a really good time doing it I
sort of went started to go a little
crazy after a while being this girl but
um the humor was what kept you alive but
I've noticed
I mean you've certainly departed a lot
from the image that you had as a child I
mean right now you're doing the the
guest jeans and yes I am we actually
have that photo if we could put it up
let me see that there we go help me out
here Andy Wow
drew I'm I'm sorry but it's on the cue
cards I have to do is I we don't lie on
this show everything's written down for
me
the network is so scared
[Music]
like write everything down for that
monkey but there's that one you wearing
a tattoo I was looking through some of
those earlier as part of my job what do
you have on your ankle across a sort of
fourth angled crosses across at each
angle and it has Rose vines going
through it and I put it on there about
five years ago Wow how many tattoos do
you have um I have five mm-hmm no I'm
not gonna get but what kind are you have
a cross and well um yes I have a cross
on my ankle I have a blue moon on my toe
what makes you think of that what makes
you think of like I've got to have a
moon well what made you think of it I
don't know I I'm just saying what made
you think okay I've got to have that
pretty permanent decision actually a
friend of mine that we were walking past
a tattoo shop one day when let's get
matching tattoos mm-hmm and that's how
it happened and it's still there right
so they're not those fake kind I get the
fake kind of I have those two those are
a lot of fun
um and then I have um cherubs growing
growing I hope they're not growing um
along the base of my back all right what
what are you doing now um right now I'm
I flew in from Texas and I'm living in a
town called Brackett Ville believe me
none of you have heard of it and if you
have I'm sorry we don't even have a
mailman
we have nothing and but it's great
because you're very at one with nature
and this is what are you filling in
Texas this is Brackett Ville Texas Oh
sounds like a charming I forgot to tell
you why I was there I'm here because I'm
shooting a Western uh-huh a female
Western with them me and three other
lovely ladies and a McDowell Mary Stuart
Masterson Madeleine Stowe and I think
it's gonna be really exciting
yeah that sounds neat what is it a
problem living in Brackett Ville Texas
you're obviously used to all the
amenities well I'm used to a big city in
everything but like I said I mean it's
beautiful you know they gave me this
convertible to drive and you know it's
very funny looking they gave you a
convertible well the rental company did
and
that's why I get clear what did that
like I want to go home have a big bow on
it or anything okay this is this is what
you get while you're here and you know I
sort of cruise on the open roads and
it's um it's amazingly beautiful and I'd
like to live out in the country someday
there's nothing you miss about 7-eleven
I miss the 7-eleven all right
don't we all don't we all all right well
we're gonna have to go thanks very much
for coming on my first show thank you
for having me it was a real honor thank
you and we will be right back with Tony
Randall I just wanted to say before
anything else that it's a real honor to
be on your first show well thank you
very much that's nice of you
[Music]
not so great an onerous to be the first
guest
[Applause]
I'm sure I'm sure John will let you wear
the medal is for five or ten minutes
still I thought I ought to dress for it
I did you look very nice thank you do I
thought this was dressing up in my
generation this is a nerd I'm dressing
up for me this is dressing
you're not amused by me at all yeah I'm
certainly amused by your clothes no no
this is what we call a Bar Mitzvah suit
and I no no you look very very nice in
it indeed thank you thank you very much
no I'm going to a friend's wedding after
the show no you should go to a friend's
Bar Mitzvah I feel like I'm being taken
to the woodshed the talkshow woodshed
how you enjoying the show so far
come on I'm Bob and I'm leaving I'm in
there I'm trying huh well I I I thought
the leg wrestling was clever
I just said to myself as I'm sure
everybody in America did if I had a talk
show that's what I'd put on it amuses me
that's all you have to do know that
that's the highest form of art when you
pander to your audience that's no good
pandering no no not even a little you
must stick by your conscience artistic
conscience such as it is and do what
amuses you so the leg wrestling's good
I'd keep it in I'd have it every night
yeah and then you could have very sort
of variation on it nude like grass yeah
write it down yeah nude there you go
past me how do you like the set I like
it I might be tidier right no no
III think any set with a picture of Joe
Franklin on it is real yeah I believe in
that I believe in the things I believe
there you're sticking by your guns yeah
you're doing what you believe in and
you're bound to succeed you think yeah I
know it then let's all give me a big
hand
well
[Music]
our first show is over many viewers are
probably turning in for the night now
well I don't want to discourage people
from watching later with Bob Costas I do
realize that there are many people out
there who are insomniac and would love
some help getting to sleep but one of
the things I can offer as a new host is
my beautiful singing voice so for those
who need it I'd like to offer this
simple lullaby
[Music]
[Applause]
blast of snow mega
[Music]
[Applause]
No
boom on below that's sorry
[Applause]
I also want to thank Andy Richter the
next one good seven I have to laugh at
time tonight I hope you'll come back and
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you